it was a study abroad program and they
were like go to rush you'll get a minor
so Burton is 1995 this is when the mob
runs everything and they tell us that
they're like listen we've paid off the
Mafia to keep you safe I'm in st.
Petersburg Russia going this trip just
got awesome and so they picked us two
young gangsters the word for that in
Russian is banditti and so you had two
Russian gangsters who were there to
protect you protect walk dust class walk
us back from class lived with us take us
on field trips they're like don't talk
to them they're in the Mafia I was like
oh they're gonna be my best friends
right so I grabbed a bottle of vodka
knocked on their door and I planned a
sentence I was gonna say Stella Lucia -
would Bertram Brianna got a boat to
Corsica
but the second I'm face to face with a
real gangster tattoos wife beater
cigarette track pants and he just looks
at me I freeze and everything I plan on
saying flooded him I had an all I said
to him in Russian and his doorway was I
am the machine and he starts laughing
hysterically brings me in a room full of
all Russian gangsters like stop tell
them what you said I'm like and they
loved me so you okay so then what
happens you're you've got the Russian
mafia and you're known as the machine
how much do you hang with these guys um
go places with them every night they ran
our trip they could walk into my clásico
machine but you're glad I just leave
class it was the greatest summer of my
life
we was we ran a pool hall scam we stole
a boat did you really do these things oh
oh it gets worse okay we take a trip to
Moscow overnight train trip I tell a
girl he's got to answer the door I go
hey we should get a nice car he goes I
can't go different mafia runs train did
from off Iran's Moscow Oh so the guy
who's with you in Moscow can't come with
you I mean I can't come with you must
enter you have to go with someone else
who knew gangsters he introduces me at
the train he goes guys this is the
machine if you give the Machine vodka
we'll have a great time so he's like
this is Egor this is Egor I was like
great
they take me to first class and we start
boozing hard they're like I can't wait
to play with a machine right
the conductor comes in he's like this is
a present for the Machine and like get
ripped off his stars and stripes I'm 22
years old one oh these machine stories
might have gotten out of control
yeah yeah words out about you in Russia
oh and we drink all the booze and then
they go we go to the bar cart walk into
the bar cart a big you were just his
machine go behind the bar and grab bread
clad but I'm like I'm learning the
language right no not through textbooks
I'm learning it my way by joining the
Mafia right he's like grab grab bread
and on my crab crab cheese sealed I'm
like grabs vodka is already not one
he's like grab the money I'm like huh
huh he goes grab the money and I realize
we're robbing the bar cart and I'm the
one doing it hooked on phonics style go
back to our first-class cabinets start
drinking hard teacher shows up she hears
about it she goes opens the door with
that liberal arts confidence you know
it's just like this is over you're done
mister get up and big Igor looks at me
smiles takes a big sip of vodka spits it
in her eyes and goes no one talks to the
machine like that [ __ ] this is our self
don't worry machine when it gets dark we
have good time like when it's dark we
make good time when it gets dark we have
good time so okay so please I need to
know what did you say you're with these
guys is a train trip ever end oh yeah it
is even dark yet
yeah pulls out the keys and he goes
we're robbing the whole train and I was
like let's do it okay let's start with
my class so we robbed them first
and then we robbed the whole train and
then we do robbed the whole train and we
just drank hard okay
then eventually you pull into the
station there must be repercussions
right one of Moscow
door opens same teachers like they've
alerted the police and I see two cops
talking to my whole class they're upset
they've been robbed I get it snitches
get stitches yeah big igor's completely
unfazed like don't worry I speak to
police for both of us and I was like oh
this will be perfect
grabs a bottle of vodka likes a
cigarette goes to the cop who's taking a
statement grabs him by the arm spins him
around and just starts screaming and
robbery in Russian I would handle bad
now the cops staring at me and I hear
him bark out boys it is good day which I
don't know if that means but it doesn't
sound like you're okay stay there right
I walked to the cop who's standing in
front of the class I just robbed next to
the gangster I robbed them with thinking
this isn't how I plan on spending my
second junior year right I give I give
five steps from the cop who looks
impatient he takes two big steps grabs
me by the arm spins me away from my
class away from me or gets right in my
face and it goes so I understand you're
the machine I'm not in trouble and he
gets so close to me I can smell this
morning cigarette he goes no that [ __ ]
this is Russia how are you not dead I
don't know how you're not dead oh we had
to take the same trip back to st.
Petersburg look the same gangsters on
the same train yeah you know what the
teachers came up to me and they're like
we need you to party with him again I
was like turns out that no one got hurt
and it worked so yeah so yeah
you